yeah to discuss an antitrust decision
that we have just taken and a
commissioner when I'll give a statement
before we move on to our traditional
questions in answer session
well thank you very much today the
Commission has decided to find Google
one point four nine billion euros for
breaking EU antitrust rules Google has
engaged in illegal practices when it
comes to their search advertising
brokering in order to cement its
dominant market position this is the
third antitrust find that we have
imposed on Google in June 2017 we find
Google for its illegal behavior in
comparison shopping services and in July
2018 we find Google for its illegal
behavior relating to the Android mobile
operating system for mobile apps and
services I'd like to address what Google
has done has been doing to comply with
those two earlier decisions but before I
do that just let me give you a few more
details on the decision that we took
today as you know when you type in a
query into Google's search engine you
not only get the results but you also
get ads that are based on the words that
you type in in fact that sort of
advertising is by far
Google's main source of revenue
Google sells advertising on its own
search pace the Google also has a
business of brokering advertising space
on other websites that could include
websites like newspapers or blogs or
travel sites they will all include a
search box that's the point
and
having searched on your sites that
allows the owners of those websites to
make money in much the same way Google
does on its own sites by selling the
space to search results these other
websites
well they rely on an advertising broker
and Google is by far the biggest of
those brokers with his platform absence
for search and this market is an
important market because it's an entry
point for competitors including other
search providers for online advertising
platforms by gaining a foothold in
advertising brokering well then they can
grow their business or they could grow
their business and try to challenge
Google in the general search advertising
Google is dominance when it comes to
online advertising brokering market with
market shares in Europe well above
seventy percent since 2006 and there are
high barriers to entry which makes it
very hard for competitors to come in
despite that competition should be
possible in this market different
websites can use different brokers and
the same website can actually use more
than one broker to provide different ads
indeed our investigation showed that
many websites had an interest to use
more than one broker today's decision is
about how Google abused its dominance to
stop websites using brokers other than
the Adsense platform for the most
importance websites which Google calls
direct partners Google provide brokering
services through tailored agreements our
investigation looked at more than 200 of
those agreements and they contained all
at least one type of restrictions that
harm competition these different types
of restrictions
they often overlapped in time the first
type is than exclusivity provision which
Google began to include in its contracts
from 2006 it meant that the most
commercially important direct partners
were prevented from sourcing search apps
from Google's web from Google's rivals
on any of their websites the second type
is called premium placement Google began
including it in this contract from 2009
to replace over time the existing
explicit exclusivity provisions these
clauses they didn't completely stop
direct partners sourcing ads from
Google's rivals but they meant that
direct partners would have to take a
minimum of search ads from Google and
put them in the most visible and most
profitable parts of the page so the best
web page space where users were most
likely to click was still reserved for
Google the third type of restriction
even allowed Google to control our
website displayed search ads of Google's
rivals under this clause website owners
they would have to get the written
approval from Google before changing the
way they displayed search ads of
Google's rivals right down to the size
the collar button even the front of
those house as in many digital markets
search advertising is a marketer with
strong network effects so the more users
you have the more valuable your services
becomes to each and every one of them
lad meant that to compete effectively
you need to build scale
is restriction restrictive clauses while
they led to a vicious circle
Google's rivals they were unable to grow
and to compete and as a result of that
well website Sur owners a website had
limited options for selling advertising
space on those websites and were forced
solely to rely on Google and as a result
from that Google benefited from network
effects and became even stronger there
was no reason for Google to include
these restrictive clauses in their
contracts except to keep rivals out of
the market and this is why we concluded
that between 2006 and 2016
Google's behavior was illegal under EU
antitrust rules it prevented its rivals
from having a chance to innovate and to
compete in the markets on their merits
advertisers and website owners they have
less choice and likely faith faced
higher prices that would be passed on to
consumers the fine of 1.4 9 billion
euros reflect the series and the
sustained nature of Google's
infringement and anyone of course who
have suffered damage because of Google's
behavior can also claim compensation
from Google through national course
Google removed these illegal
restrictions from its contract in 2016
around the time when we issued a
statement of objection at a minimum our
decision requires Google's to put a stop
to those restrictions or any other
restriction with an equivalent effect
and not to reinstate them let me now go
back for a moment to the Google Shopping
and the Google Android decisions and
address the information that we have
about the changes Google has made
in the way it's does business I'll start
with the Google shopping case back in
2017 in June when we took our decision
Google systematically put its own
shopping comparison service at the top
of the first page of search results in
the shopping unit no no competing
comparison shopping service was able to
appear in the shopping unit they weren't
average to be found and pays for in
search results our decision requires
Google to treat rival comparison
shopping services the same way as they
treat their own and it's up to Google to
find an effective way to do that Google
has chosen to open up its shopping unit
which was a set previously reserved
exclusively for Google's own services
since September 2017
rival comparison shopping services has
been able to bid for space in the
shopping unit it has taken time for this
mechanism to show results the data that
we shared in June last year found that
around 30 percent of shopping units
included at least one of Google's
competitors the latest data they show
that these thirty percent now has
increased to 75 percent of shopping
units that includes at least one of
gores
rivals in the June 2018 data we also
found that only just about 6% of clicks
in the Google Shopping unit went to
competitors now this six percent has
also increased around 40 percent of
clicks on products results now go to
competitors to Google these numbers
reflect the situation after Google made
changes earlier
address criticism that previous numbers
were inflated by competitors that
actually did not really compete in
shopping comparison these changes now
require all participants services to
have a sufficient range of offers and a
set of core comparison functions Google
also just announced a feature that it
will let users choose choose whether the
shopping unit should show links to
comparison shopping sites or directly to
those sites where you find the merchants
and the product as it used to do with
this new feature the user will be able
to switch or to toggle between the
current window that shows links going
directly to merchants and windows that
will show links going to shopping
comparison sites Google's competitors
and this means that users will be able
to choose what kind of results they want
to see all these are positive
developments obviously we will keep
monitoring the market shopping is just
one part of specialized search Google
also offer services of that kind when it
comes to jobs and local search the
decision we took in June 2017 gives us a
framework to look at other services
exactly as jobs or local search what we
have found is that those different
specialized services well they have some
things in common but they are also
different there are important
differences among them so we need to
look individually at those services and
we are noted that Google is rolling out
certain changes to its product in these
areas and this is of course something
that we will look at closely I now like
to turn to the Android decision of July
2018 this was a case about the type of
restriction
that Google imposed on mobile device
manufacturers and network operators that
used Android first Google de-facto
required manufacturers to pre install
Google search and browser apps second
Google paid manufacturers of phones and
network operators to make sure that only
the Google Apps was pre-installed and
thirdly Google obstructed the
development of competing mobile
operating systems these restrictions
they all aimed to ensure that search on
mobile devices was directed to Google
search cementing Google's position in
the market the decision meant that
Google can no longer oblige device
manufacturers to take Google search and
browser products if they take the Google
Playstore it also meant means it also
means that rival search and browser
providers well they can strike exclusive
deals with device manufacturers to pre
install their products instead of Google
products while this of course creates
new commercial opportunities that did
not exist before there were concerns
that this was not sufficient to restore
competition Google has now announced
that it intends to provide a choice
screen for Android users in Europe for
Android phones that already exist in the
market and also for new Android phones
where Google products may be
pre-installed and this should let
consumers choose which search and
browser provider they want on their
Android phone we've seen in the past
that a choice screen can be an effective
way to promote user choice in the Google
Android case it has the potential to
give users a real choice of
what search and browser they want on
their Android device this should also
allow Google's rivals to be chosen up
front by users in cases where Google has
been pre-installed on the phone it is
welcome that Google is stepping up its
efforts in connection with the Google
Android decision and of course we will
watch closely to see how the choice
screen mechanism evolves platforms like
google play a vital role in digital
markets businesses and consumers
well they depend on platforms to get the
best out of digitization so illegal
behavior in these cases of course it's a
very serious effect we're thinking very
carefully about the future of
competition because everything becomes
digitized last year I appointed three
special advisers to look at the
challenges that competition policy faces
as digital technology changes every
industry we know I'm looking forward to
receiving their report very soon in our
reflection for the future as well as our
enforcement work our aim will of course
remain the same to make sure that market
works well so European consumers have
choice innovative products and fair
prices thank you thank you proceed to
your questions to us to remind you that
we have experts at hand to speak to you
afterwards they know everything about
Google Google shopping to Google Adsense
rumor has it they were even on Google+
at some stage so if you could start with
your questions relating directly to to
the case and then we will take your
questions on other topics and please
remember to state the name of your your
name and the name of your media and I'll
start with Jorge who was hands up
halfway through the
thank you very much Ricardo two
questions the first one I mean this is
the the final case of the Google Saga
with all the issues that has been on
solutions proposed by Google could you
say that this is definitely case closed
or there are some other issues may be
related to other fields for example how
that eyes managed or other concerns that
cool reflect in a future state about the
objections or something and a second
question this is the most important case
and in the competition field that the
Commission has deal with over the past
years and also in your during your
mandate do you think that this case will
increase your chances of becoming a
becoming for example a candidate for for
the presidency of the Commission given
that tomorrow will be an important day
for you well final and final I said we
we see positive developments in both the
Google shopping case and the Google
absence case we will keep monitoring
these developments because as I speak I
don't know what will be the final
details as to how this choice screen
will be presented to users and we're
still looking into the search market for
jobs and the search market for locals we
keep getting complaints from people who
are concerned as to how these markets
work so we will keep doing our job also
in in those markets for me the most
important thing here is to enable user
choice if you if you saw what I said
initially here the change is there
always about enabling users to choose
what they want to do what product they
want to have because I think that the
ability to to choose also makes you feel
that you're in control and that's a very
important thing because when you want to
feel that the
it is actually serving you as a consumer
and not the other way around
exactly choice and being in control that
is of the essence and that I hope that
we have promotes it with the case work
in these three cases you to the second
question thank you any further questions
at this stage Lois
commissioner Louis Croft cynics just to
follow up on my colleagues questions
just now you said you gave the shopping
figures the the percentage of clicks is
that enough for you now is that what is
70 percent of clicks or two-thirds of
screens the figures that you gave is
that enough for you is that a
competitive internet market for
comparison search or would you like to
see more and secondly to follow up on
hora gay you've sat you've stood at this
podium been at conferences telling us
for several years that competition all
shouldn't be politicized do you think
that running a political campaign on
behalf of a party or being involved in
it in elections is compatible with being
a competition commissioner which is a
quasi-judicial job thank you first and
the question of whether it's it's enough
or not
I don't really think that we should be
the the final judge of that because
there's no magic number nor in in these
cases when I give you in a numbers it is
to say that this market has improved as
said in 70% of cases where the shopping
unit is shown a rival to Google would
appear and I think that in 40% of cases
more than one rival would appear so you
see that rivals are gaining visibility I
do hope that this market will develop it
has developed a lots since we took the
decision where there was no rival in the
shopping unit the point is that if a
market is to develop consumers will have
to use their opportunities to make
choices and as that we will keep
following to see how will this develop I
for one think that it could be a good
thing that you can choose if you want to
see the products or if you want to see
the shopping comparison services that
can allow you to compare prices if
things are in store when it can be
shipped at what cost
all of that content that comes with
shopping comparison but that's my
preference and other consumers will have
other preferences one of the things that
this commission has been very careful
about is to make sure that we have rules
that are transparent and public so that
people can see that we do our job as we
should do it
and that goes for each and every one of
us and that of course goes for me as
well I will be active in the coming
months to see if I can enable more
voters to go to vote that I think is
only for anyone in in office is the
thing for everyone to say to daughters
mothers fathers grandmothers
grandchildren let's make this a
celebration of democracy let's go vote
the latest numbers I saw was that only
one out of two Europeans are considering
to vote in the European elections and
that I do hope that everyone will engage
in changing not with a necessarily a a
wish as to work work for this party at
that party but to get out the vote and
that I find is completely compatible
with everything that anyone is doing
q further questions on the Sun and then
Oh
and Thank You commissioners I'm done or
for Politico
in the Adsense probe there are a number
of
found findings for example in relation
to the markets the dominance of Google
in market of online advertising and
perhaps also some findings of data that
could those feed into other issues that
have been raised in relation to online
advertising which now for example the
French and UK competition authorities
are looking into
that that I don't know as you say this
is this it can be very relevant for
national competition authorities to look
into the behavior in this market because
we have this paradox we see giant
companies with a global footprint and
yet the advertising market is national
we would have no Google cases if we by
definition thought that all markets were
global because businesses are global
here we have a national footprint we
have many many differences between
member states when it comes to the
advertising markets and the search
market as well the Czech Republic in in
particular but you'd find a number of
other differences we do hope of course
that the case work that we do inspire
and enable national competition
authorities but I wouldn't know exactly
how this case directly relates to the
cases that colleagues are doing
nationally you personnel come back
i Commissioner Jones freighter from CNN
International Commissioner added to the
previous finds for US companies does the
EU have something against US tech firms
well I don't think that the the truck
companies feel it like that
at least I think they would like to be
included because what you see is that we
have had quite a number of antitrust
cases over the years what they deal with
is the way you do business in Europe and
you're more than welcome to come here
and do business only you should compete
on the merits and this is what we saw in
the truck cartel this is what we have
seen in the Google cases this is what we
have seen in all the many cartels on car
parts I hope you enjoyed the wonderful
infographic on that so that you can
imagine and remember every time you sit
in your car the phone in your seats has
been customized the seatbelt has been
customized when you put your key in or
oppress the bottom the alternator has
been customized when the lights are then
turn on then have been customized the
businesses in those and many other car
part cartels they come from a number of
different countries again what's
important is that they do business in
Europe and that's is what is triggering
a fine
if you do not play by our rule book
you see how she does what an illness can
you say anything about the calculation
of the fine is the abuse less severe
than Google Shopping and an Android
when a finest calculators is first and
foremost that we look at the turnover in
the affected market and you have the
search advertising market I think most
of us think about it
when we do a Google search then you see
that vert izing that comes with it
depending on what you've been looking
for and that's the that's a huge bulk of
revenue when it comes to search
advertising the Brooke brokering market
is somewhat smaller when you have a
search box on a travel site any other
sites
well then both the one who owns the site
can monetize the space but of course the
broker will also monetize the space so
the reason of the fine when you sort of
mentally compare with the turnover of
the Google company as such reflects the
fact that the brokering market is
smaller than the search advertising
market is that of course the fact that
it lasted for ten years makes it a more
important offense so we had a couple of
sort of aggravating factors but it is
sort of the turnover in the market
that's the most important trigger in the
level of fine
hello commissioner I'm over here
Commission eight out of all of the tech
giants but you've dealt with in your
term which one would you say has been
the naughtiest and which one have you
cost the most money thank you well you
know since the gdpr I don't keep lists
and they are very different very
different here the total of the Google
find I think they are eight point two
five billion euros something like that
but still we're not at the even in total
10% cap of global turnover with the
front and in Rochelle
thank you very much and rescue from El
Diario Spain I would like to ask you a
practical question you have just said
that that defines two to Google are up
to eight point two billion euros are
this fine getting paid how do they pay
when what do you do with the money where
the money goes what are things thank you
in either you can you can pay us in in
in cash with a financial instrument or
you can make a bank guarantee you have
to do that before you file an appeal of
the decision if you want to do that so
the fine is placed on a closed account
we cannot touch it businesses cannot
touch it if if the decision is appealed
and then the fine will remain there till
the court has decided if we were right
or wrong of course we do our best to
make sure that the court agrees with us
if the court agrees with us learn the
fine is distributed to member states in
the same key as all Member States pay
their membership contribution I only
remember the Dainius numbers but if it's
a fine of a hundred million euros it
would be two million in the Danish
context so you see the differences
between member states well of course
that would be quite varied how much you
get from it but it goes back to member
state and this is of course to make sure
that there is no suspicion that we have
you know an incentive when coffers are
empty to take out our fine mechanism and
start writing out fines because we lack
money that cannot happen
Rochelle den casita
Rochelle Penske with the FT you
mentioned you were looking into jobs and
into local search and I know that there
were some travel websites that had
originally complained and that Google
has search services for both flights and
hotels and I'm just wondering if those
are at all being well no not those
specific ones that you mentioned these
are markets that develops and assets
Google also changing their behavior in
this market and this we will take into
consideration when we investigate
further where we have strong
complainants in the local search and in
jobs
Koshien
Kishida wasn't from Parr just going back
to Adsense one of the parties affected
by this case have just put out a
statement saying while they welcome the
Commission's decision finding Google
they are also calling on the Commission
to require remedies to effectively
restore competition they're saying that
a season desist order was not going to
restore competition and could we get
your thoughts on that Thanks this is of
course one of the the things that we
think about the most also when we are
sort of more forward-looking
because when you are in in fast moving
markets and even if we were as speedily
as one could possibly expect of us the
risk is still of course that the market
will have moved on and it's very
difficult to restore competition as it
were what we have have seen in in the
shopping decision in the Android
decision is that Google is changing its
business practices when it comes to the
decision of today we saw that change or
one change in business practice when we
set the statement of objection that
these restrictive in our opinion illegal
closes they were removed from the
contracts unfortunately so far we have
no pickup from other advertising brokers
in this market there are competitors but
they are quite small so of course that's
an area of concern
Catherines your reporter usually when
companies abuse a dominant position it
results in higher prices for the goods
and once that question is addressed then
prices you know should really go down I
suppose and I'm just wondering you know
the people who have lost art are the
people being running adsense on their
website and haven't been fully
reimbursed were those people with those
undertakings be able to seek that being
address and you know it probably isn't I
mean I'm just maybe larger companies
will go through the court system but
that seems to be quite heavy-duty
approach is there any sort of idea of
automatic remuneration for those those
websites that have essentially been if I
should I subscribe this and they've lost
revenue that they should have received
thank you well yes I think that if you
are a competitor not being able to offer
your services to a travel website or a
news website well I think you might have
a case I don't know but you might try to
seek for damages in national courts
could also be that a travel website
would think well I didn't have the
benefits of competition I'm afraid that
prices were higher than they should be
of course this is just speculation on my
site but I would understand why these
ideas would occur this is why you can
seek for damages in national courts and
we will of course do our best to have a
public version of the decision as fast
as possible because that decision is of
course available for those who will seek
damages in national courts because they
find that they have suffered from the
illegal Google behavior
and cue any further questions on that
sense
you
on the two first cases you're reporting
progress
does that mean that you can exclude them
any fines for non-compliance right now
and if not what would possible fines for
non-compliance depend upon rather on the
further developments of the market or
from some Google behavior you you
wouldn't we wouldn't agree on thank you
yes
as as you say if if we could prove
non-compliance from the day when we
suspected non-compliance daily penalties
penalties it could be put in place until
there was compliance when I sight the
numbers that we have now and the
intentions of Google in the in the
Android decision this is also to say
well we don't have a non-compliant issue
as it is now we will of course keep
following this market but I think it is
positive that Google takes steps that
allows for more consumer choice I of
course do hope that consumers will use
this choice and also that competitors of
rule will be able to make the best of
that because that is what these cases
are about is this to say that the
illegal Google behavior that cemented
their dominant position in search that
it stops but not only that it stops but
also that competitors can be there for
us as consumers to have a real choice
thank you
thank you I'm seeing Italian is anyone
else still in Adsense or can I move over
- no then I will move over Kalavati and
then dahveed
one morning Commissioner gala voted in
Cronos III is just a question on the
judgment by the you court on Turkish
they stated that it was not state aid
the intervention of the inter banking
private funder I wonder if you have
anything to say about that and also if I
may I mean a terrain C was indirectly
but heavily damaged by that decision
have you anything to say about that I
mean the damage was political because if
that decision would have not been taken
the banker pariah of a Trulia would have
been simply saved without the burden
sharing which was politically very
damaging for materials I just wondered
about thank you well on the judgment in
itself of course we'll have to come back
because the assessment about the use of
of these funds is an assessment that you
will have seen also in previous cases
it's in line with commissioned practice
it's not something specific to the
Turkish situation when you look at the
four small banks and of course banking
through shell being one of them well I
think the the thing that's that
triggered that resolution was a decision
by the Bank of Italy in 2015 that was
what's put these four banks into
resolution and one of the things that I
think it is important to always maintain
is that depositors they were protected
at all times that doesn't change the
fact that some people were still miss
old and this is why we work with Italian
authorities to make sure that we can set
up schemes that compensates people who
have been miss old who thought that they
had a simple accounts and were protected
by a deposit scheme but then it turned
out that they had bought a product that
could be bailed in and I think it is
important that we do that for obvious
social reasons and for reasons of
fairness we've had two different schemes
one where it was an individual approach
and one where it was a more sort of
group based approach where you try to
find out well who could have been harmed
here and that we do and we are I think
in very constructive discussions with
the Italian government as to how can we
proceed this because we share the goal
to make sure that people who are Mis
sold that they can't be compensated
obviously the banks themselves should do
that they are the first first to call if
that cannot happen then of course for
everyone else in the form of the states
being able to step in
now eat carrot ready ready he'll follow
up on the Turkish judgment first of all
since you have said that you want to
come back on the judgment are you going
to appeal this judgment or are you going
to change your policy approach on the
issue since Turkish was a president and
the president a president used in other
cases like the four banks and other so
what do you mean when you say we will
come back on the judgment second
question yesterday the president of the
Italian Bank Association asked for your
step down because in a way for the fact
that Turkish was use as a president a
president at the end of the day it have
an important impact not only on the
government of that time but also on the
financial system so how do you respond
how do you answer to these critics and
if I may not date on
Alitalia long another long story
what are you going to do since we are
still waiting a restructuring plan for a
bridge loan that it's not a bridge loan
but different sort of a thank you on the
last question the update on
Alitalia that can be very short on our
side on the state's discussion there are
no further comments
you know the sale handled by the Italian
authorities is ongoing and we have no
decision on the state age sites as of
yet when you look at the bank Atticus
sort of the Commission reasoning is is
not new what we reason and has been
reasoning before is the fact that if you
have a payment that is mandatory and if
the fund that is created with the
mandatory payment can be the use of that
font is imputed to the states well then
we find state 8 in the Italian case what
happened was that you both have the fund
with the mandatory payment and then you
have a voluntary arm and the voluntary
arm then stepped in and it's what the
mandatory arm couldn't do because that
would be state 8 and that means that the
situation on ground would be slightly
more nuanced than the way you put it and
a sense when it comes to the for smaller
Italian banks it wasn't a decision by us
that put these back these banks into
resolution in 2015 it was the decision
of the Italian National Bank so I think
when you look into this you see a much
more varied picture with the role that
Italian banks are such a playing with
the voluntary arm and the the role of
national authorities with us when we do
this data at assessment and whether we
will appeal it or not we have not taken
a decision because it was so recent so
we have to analyze more in depth
thank you I have hotly again second
round
sorry about that it's on a different
issue now on the possible merger between
Commerce Bank and dodge Bank since
tomorrow I think there is an important
meeting scheduled with with the board of
the two banks I would like to know how
do you see these this potential merger
also in the light of your recent
decision of the artem CMS merger thank
you
of course I'm I'm reading the papers too
but but on our working desk we have no
murder
we have no announced major we have no
notified merger
we have no murdering process so on the
specifics obviously I have no comments
just one thing about mergers that create
big entities when we have a competition
concern is not because you could become
big it's because that your customers has
no one else to turn to if prices go up
choice go down innovation is at risk of
stopping that is what we're looking at
is not sheer size in itself it is if you
when you merge say well then prices can
come up and consumers shouldn't have the
same choice as before can you go to
someone else would there be someone else
who would still give me a loan at an
affordable interest rate or give me
choice of different products that would
be what we would be analyzing and in the
Siemens Alstom case you know that for
the huge majority of the market metros
trams intercity trains urban signalling
other problems were solved or we had no
problems because if the merged entity
will say well we will charge a higher
price and metros people who go to
someone else to buy their metro trains
no concerns in that respect we only had
concerns in in mainline signalling and
very high-speed train because our
analysis also looking forward 5-10 years
would show that if the merged entity
decided to have higher prices for
mainline signalling there would be no
one else to turn to
and then
obviously customers would have to pay
these higher prices so this is what we
look at it's not the fact that you
emerged to become big it's the fact that
customers and consumers has no one else
to turn to and you can see in the past
that big companies has merged to become
even bigger companies in beer and cement
and steel in a number of areas dairy
products where you find that it's not
size it's the market functioning that is
of our interest as commissioner
consumers can use forgive me for going
back to Turkish I think my colleague
asked you one question that you didn't
answer to which is according to the
sentence the the fact that the walls I
mean the Commission has not demonstrated
that that was stated because of the
mandatory character of the rule that was
money coming from the voluntary arm so
there is a clear difference between the
judgment by the tribunal the you and
your judgment are you going to appeal
this decision because of this clear
difference or are you going to continue
on this in on this the same policy
because you say it that way it has been
used as a in the past
but actually it happens I'm afraid also
often that I don't precisely ask the
questions answer the questions asked but
here actually I think I did answer that
we don't know yes if we will appeal or
not because the judgment is very recent
and we need to know what is the
reasoning what should be our approach in
this issue it is obviously obvious that
we will have to address this one way or
another because this is a court decision
and that has effect on the way we work
and the way the world works so we will
come back on the exact issue of how we
will deal with the judgments my point
was just to say that before one makes
sort of a full chain of events to say
that because of this decision something
also happened in other bands and other
banks and other banks to say I think now
just stop look at the Turkish decision
specifically because when you look at
the four smaller banks
it was another chain of events that led
to the result that is on ground today
many thanks commissioner I will take one
last but it has to be quick dr. tom
you
Jennifer's just a short question to gas
prom because last year you had two
commitments from gas prom I just wonder
whether I was a commission as some
monitoring about the implementation of
these commitments and how are you
satisfied with this we do monitor this
commitment as sets when the decision was
was public for us this is actually where
enforcement starts because now we
enforce the binding commitments on gas
from to change the behavior in the
European gas market and this is also why
we have a trustee to oversee that
Gazprom is actually doing as they should
do because these I indeed binding
commitments and if you as a company do
not live up to binding commitments the
result would be a fine it's some time
ago I had the latest update but when I
had an update gas prom was implementing
as they should the new clauses are for
instance the price review mechanism
change of delivery points in their
contracts with those customers who
wanted to have it
thank you that concludes our press
conference today Thank You commissioner
Rivas Nia the press conference this
press conference or tie the college
readout with commissioners from applause
King and Gabrielle they will be joining
joining the press room shortly for that
so thank you very much and stay seated
thank you